[Aplausos]
[Música]
podia-se o que nessa janela está sabe
dizer se é possível algum trabalho
encontrar trabalho a que nunca falta
quem sabe trabalhar o que fará com que o
compadre na sua até radilla hoje o circo
lavrador lavrador de terra mar numa
espécie de terra que oposta futebol
isso aqui de nada adianta pouco existe
otra
mas diga me retirava fique mais fab
cabular é assim mesmo erro de palco essa
história que eu trouxe pra vocês é de
joaquina isso é minha mãe que faleceu já
tem 21 anos desencarnou eu agora vou
entrar no mundo pra vocês mundo de
severino
acho que vocês viram coisa estranha é
severino né e porquê porque eu sou da eu
faço parte do teatro não é só da rua e
vim trazer a história um pouco de vocês
vocês têm uma vivência de uma mulher
negra trans e eu tô aqui eu vou daqui a
pouco começado começo da minha vida que
sempre as pessoas dão nome às pessoas
elas mandam no corpo da gente a gente
não tem poder para mandar o nosso corpo
e as pessoas que dizem você tem que
fazer isso você tem que fazer aquilo né
meus pais por ser do interior minha mãe
nem cantar ea mulher curandeira e daí
minha mãe faleceu fiquei com 12 anos
agora só tinha eu vou fazer o que dá
vida e daí eu comecei a trabalhar no era
criança mas eu trabalhava cortando cana
limpava mato trabalhava na obra ganhará
comissão era plantar batata ia na casa
de farinha que é do interior sabe disso
e às vezes não ganhava nada foi a comida
né e às vezes é apanhava porque apareceu
com mulheres desistem além de ser preto
tem jeito de [ __ ]
quero popular isso pra você seu severino
daí eu parti pra uma cidade chamada
fiquei sozinha naquele sofrimento partir
para a união dos palmares em alagoas o
pernambucana nasceu no sertão de
pernambuco no sítio e daí parte e com
minha alma sempre feminino mas que a
sociedade dizer que eu era sivirino por
isso que eu me identifico muito com o
filme vida morte e vida severina que
você viu a entrada porque entrado a
música deve ficar me representa e
repreendeu vim né
e eu quero mostrar pra vocês um pouco eu
vou mostrar quando cheguei a união
também trabalhar em casa de família
quando bateu na porta a trabalhar dizia
você não é mulher é um homem então civil
continuava jully care não você aqui não
você pode até fazer uma faxina arredar
um prato de comida pra você comer eu
limpava repassava pano e você nem por
direito ainda tem poeira limpe e nem da
vassoura bota a mão no esgoto que você
se você é [ __ ] era o palavrão que
recebia
limpe você deixou surdo argento era isso
que a gente passava e aprender e jada
botafogo no fogo pela ofran todo mundo
ria mas era o que a gente passava
pedradas e travesti e uma mulher transe
não é fácil principalmente quando a
gente vêm da roça e daí eu sempre digo
ainda continue vida e morte e severina
vir a maceió nesta que mas eu não vinha
de menor
cheguei aqui eu acho que tinha uns 13 14
ano com isso a avenida da paz foi
emprego que eu encontrei
ainda tentei conseguir emprego e não
conseguiram a quem vai entregar [ __ ]
não e ninguém vai tomar água
meu filho vai tomar água no copo que
[ __ ] toma
eu não quero você quer dizer que eu vou
sobreviver quer que eu faça poder
sobreviver e agora o que o brasil me da
minha sociedade estudo mas é uma coisa
que eu fui nunca deixei de estudar no
estudo não você é [ __ ] pra quem vai pra
escola o professor dizer que você não
gosta de mulher só de homem eu entrava
de mulheres que aquele jeito me botar
meu batom que naquela que era button 24
hora que é da época vai lembrar que não
sabia nem a pau
o beijo vermelho chegar lá toda a boca
toda vermelha e entrava na escola de
leitura você vai pra falar eu não vou
enfrentava cheguei mas eu dou fui
procurar emprego e aí uma amiga minha
falou aqui você vai ter emprego emprego
que é a rua de meu deus vou fazer o quê
na rua e daí conheci a grande avenida da
paz chega na avenida parte do menor
com isso a prostituição cheguei lá eu
toda a mente feminina e queria sempre
viveu uma vida de mulher primeiro
cliente que para disse eu não quero
saber por ser mulher quero saber da sua
genitália
eu quero era isso e sim aqui meu deus eu
me escondendo eu não queria disse meu
pai que mundo é esse
por isso que eu digo você divide morte
não se vê ninguém continuou na imagem
feminina a imagem de mulher e ainda vai
mostrar pra vocês a sua fala viver de
profissão a vida fácil não é cada capa
ver pra ver
eu vou botar uma roupa pra vocês só você
ver um pouquinho não vou ficar caramba é
uma interpretação zinha uma reta do
teatro a gente vai mostrando pra vocês
um pouquinho na noite eu passei pra são
paulo e lá é muito frio de são paulo a
belo horizonte belo horizonte viajei
pelo mundo afora foi a europa também na
itália
ai que não tão bonita área você vai
ganhar dinheiro com água e ficar rica
milionária e quem não quer ficar é um
ponto que quer ficar rico você vai
comprar uma casa um apartamento em 36 de
meu deus então tem pra onde né
lá é muito frio eu não sabia falar a
língua um casaco uma volta em cima nua
você imagina mais jovem e até agora vou
fazer 49 anos imagine eu na época com 20
anos é bem novinha né
era usada vocês sabem que o preço de uma
mulher negra é diferente de um preço uma
mulher branca através de janeiro na rua
se o problema era sempre uma branca para
a negra 20 e 30 e tem que ter a
genitália grande que não ganhava e o
cabelo afro não se podia usar esse
cabelo e chovendo era cabelo liso nariz
nariz feito porque a gente está com uma
maquiagem branca porque a preta ela não
valia nada correu sempre interpretar
essas horas no palco que a carne mais
barata é a carne negra cargo do mercado
eu ficava nessa posição a noite toda na
itália frio chovendo ou fazendo sol o
vento - 5 - 20 e rindo impecável
andou no corpo dores do frio né problema
circulatório achava lindo do meu disco
isso na itália em são paulo e no sul a
amiga dizia e muitos travesti morrendo
na rua de tiro facada nele meu deus que
mundo é esse
eu prefiro terminar sofrendo eu estou
sofrendo e que ele lá na minha cidade
ninguém está vendo pelo menos um família
queria ver esse sofrimento minha mãe já
se foi e alavanca que caía do olho meu
deus onde estou e passou voando passou
para guiar que me levou a pessoa que me
fez o que me transportou a itália é tudo
pra mim era caro como até hoje é que
muitas morrendo e onde eu continue na
vida morte e vida severina voltei pra
maceió continua em maceió
encontrei a prostituição e minhas amigas
ou morrer na rua e continua morrendo
aqui tem nenhum através de ir porque ela
não tem condição tanto na rua
trabalhando eu tô aqui não me falando da
minha vida eu tô falando de todas
travesti negra do mundo porque eu sou
afiliado ao forno transe a andra e
conseguir através de todo esse
reconhecimento
eu consegui um trabalho né através de
jorge na saúde - o chefe tá ali
maravilhosa é que ela fique de pé numa
prova que essa mulher merece e me
segurou na secretaria né vai fazer já
está ali era maravilhosa vai fazer nove
anos que eu tô me digo casada com ela me
ensinando muita briga muito natasha faça
assim e no começo eu ficava muito
chocada queria brigar com ela eu dei
porque ela pega tudo meu pé mas a pegar
pra ensinar ser melhor
em 2014 eu fui um grupo de uma trans ou
o espetáculo ia ninguém porque era um
choro travesti e rasgaram os cartazes do
show de [ __ ] eu estava sentado no ponto
e 1 uma foto da gente amor
o cara foi a campanha mulheres daí esse
modo de ver coisas da minha casa pagava
vez o enviado
e aquele show do meu deus então agora
vou fazer 11 não percebo a foto mais da
gente e que nesse projeto chamado trecho
domingo 14 a platéia
chega de 100 a 150 o atleta também não
vai ninguém mas a gente está lutando com
o projeto a gente nunca desiste
eu sou uma coisa assim joana d'arc assim
eu não vou eu não desisto nunca vou até
o final
se você perguntar o que é que tem para
investir no nosso estado
o diga você não tem nada morte e vida
severina essa daqui a minha farda
estaria até hoje assegura através de
jorginho né que me segura que não deixem
para a rua porque eu não sou segura se
acabar o contrato
vocês sabem como é que eu vou pra rua
montevidéu se você é uma marca das morta
na rua então essa farda é um salário um
pouco mas já me livra da vulnerabilidade
conseguir um trabalho também de cuidar
do paciente psiquiátrico
eu trabalho na residência terapêutica e
trabalho na bahia e chegou na comunidade
não sou preconceituoso tratada podia que
natasha e ali dentro ou médio ou curso
técnico em enfermagem é pra ele não veio
como técnica de nível com uma grande
doutor ali dentro
além do trabalho verifica pressão ali eu
tenho o maior carinho às vezes falta
tudo e dou tudo mesmo tempo que é o amor
pelas pessoas precisa tudo que eu não
tive eu dou para aquele público que
aquele povo que mora na favela que é
onde as pessoas acham que a favela mora
bandidos e não é uma família que tem
filho em minas transitar dentro que
tenha essa viver que tem esse
diferencial
e se essa vivência é uma história porque
a gente vê na prática não existe coisa
melhor né
eu digo pra vocês as pessoas mistura
gênero com o corpo
não tem nada a ver sexo é uma coisa gené
outro mas ainda continuam e continua
naquela história ainda continuo severino
daí através do palco através da arte
eu consegui me expressar e levar as
meninas ciganas da rua e colocar no
teatro né
sem projeto sem nada com a cara ea
coragem o projeto é o público que vai lá
e tv populares ganha se não tiver nós
não ganha dentro desse projeto várias
morrendo e ela continua na rua está
enfraquecendo porque eu tô vendo todas
elas voltando para a construção de novo
faltando pra rua e eu vou na casa dela
né egito enquanto o que comer confira no
álbum disputa também já com manual é
doloroso não poder fazer nada por ela e
ela me têm uma visão ela fala na taxa
você me faz ver você você trabalha no
mercado de trabalho e vai agora procurar
a escola vou estudar para ver se consigo
alguma coisa você me inspiro a fazer
isso você me leva no palco para fazer
mais que eu tenha público onu tenha ou
não tenha você me leva a lei e você é um
exemplo pra mim mas aqui você pra vocês
ainda continua verde mostra severina eu
sempre acompanho pra vocês
hoje temos vitória do brasil conseguir
meu nome e meu nome civil o nome civil
foi feito pra mim foi com a sociedade
foi pra poder
eu chego no lugar mas o nome civil do mp
segue porque a minha voz é tão alterada
com gross pequeno não tem um bloqueio
hormonal logo cedo então quando chega no
lugar as pessoas falam você fala tão
grosso
você é mulher você homem pega o
documento dele aí o documento em poder
ver quando eu dou a ele olha aí a
senhora desculpa para falar tão grosso
então as pessoas visualizam muito papel
né
as pessoas não olha a alma aquilo que
você só olha aquilo que você representa
a imagem nem no mercado de trabalho a
mesma coisa chega para trabalhar olha
pra você sim mas menina e você parece
uma mulher vendendo uma mulher
aí eu vou minha filha a gente é mulheres
a modificação vai modificando o corpo
aos poucos de acordo com sérgio né
eu sempre trabalho na faculdade nas
coisas é evan dando palestra e vou
trabalhar e mostrar a realidade
diferente e que as pessoas não
entendendo a transforma na taxa é
obrigada a aaa a tratar transexuais
nestas sessões para us través de mulher
mas sim os demais têm que respeitar é a
travesti as transexuais que são sexy
quem faz o homem a mulher não perder na
vagina mas a nossa nossa cabeça né é ser
mulher nesse país transnístria não é
fácil é muito difícil nós somos um pouco
assim vaidosa gosta de sapato alto entre
conta de coisas mais colorida porque é
um universo que a gente tem como se
apresentar nessa maneira hoje está aqui
pra vocês
essa figurino um figurino é uma mulher
que trabalha na sociedade que só chegará
com uma roupa muito penosa muita coisa a
visão já é outra diferente né isso aqui
é natasha onde fuga aí eu já entrei no
mundo anda em fukuoka e mudou de lá pra
cá eu do emprego no mercado de trabalho
que foi que mudou pra mim como natasha
lotuffo né
severino parou severino parou a severina
também a minha mãe que foi que ficou lá
atrás que lutava para sobreviver que
lutou na nona e eu fiquei como natasha
construir grandes amigos grandes
amizades né construir uma nova vida com
um pouco finaliza
a dis né na profissão ganhava claro
ganhava poder como eu queria tudo mas
não tinha conhecimento
eu não tinha e estava construindo nada
para ajudar as meninas
hoje eu vou eu não tenho nada mas tenho
muito porque eu levo o pouco que tenho
pra ela e eu sempre digo eu vou
representar a vocês são vocês é meu é
vocês sou eu um pedaço como mãe com um
pedaço dos filhos né eu tô ali sentado
não fui pensando nela estão agora na rua
trabalhando enquanto prosseguir na rua
mas morrem uma leva tiro né
liga pra mim chorando com com
dificuldade ea gente ea gente e vamos
pensando em uma maneira de a gente poder
ajudar um público o qual é a nossa
proposta é de fazer essa proposta no
futuro aqui a gente crie projetos que a
gente sente essas meninas procurar
educação como projeto foi feito em são
paulo está fazendo com a minha amiga em
são paulo
de incentivo ao mercado de trabalho com
essas meninas né
uma mulher chegou pra mim e falou assim
não é você que é ser mulher a pulso de
mama mulher representa a imagem feminina
eu tenho amor pelo corpo da mulher
primeiros 6 o corpo à bola e só não
tenho um prazer para a mulher mas admiro
a imagem agora você imagina um país
preta
naqueles dias além de ser [ __ ] é preto
que disse eu já cansei de escutar isso
leve a de preto quer ser mulher porque
tudo o que a mulher se sabe a causa tudo
cai em cima da mulher mulher sempre o
álbum fraga é sempre cai em cima da
mulher ea lei de 600 já na imagem eu
escuto sempre isso calados e do jogo até
que se obtenha verde onde a mulher falou
poxa é ser mulher ele arrumar namorado
um homem vestido de mulher
até conseguem aquecer mail calada porque
ela queria ver o que eles precisam ficar
agitada que obrigasse descansando mas
não foi muito educada com ela eu
agradecer a eles muito obrigada porque
as pessoas ela quer ver a gente agre
agressiva braba porque a sociedade ela
criou ela criou um paradigma que através
que é violenta que a travessia só para o
sexo que esta vez que ia só pra qualquer
coisa puxa delete que essa cultura que
tem né ea gente lutando quebrando
uma regra dizendo que não e essas
meninas que sai à rua a gente vamos
botar no teatro e vamos trabalhando com
elas como ter como tem a vivência na
sociedade como viver com como tem a
vivência com vocês aí do outro lado né
eu comi e ea minha felicidade aqui no
entender que não tem 10 aqui porque eu
sei que isso aí vai rodar o mundo em que
as meninas vai ser vai se sentir
representada né
uma mulher negra trans de alagoas e
fiquei muito feliz mesmo eu tô aqui na
taxa de full hd está aqui nem mais uma
vez aqui espero de está estudando muito
o brother que sair daqui para frente e
tomar entre as dúvidas está mudando
muito obrigado joga em minha música que
me lê também lá na minha terra minha
mesmo um pouco a mais até a cova da
pedra pública pagará também enfocou
adiantassem pedrada ea mas a liga me
ainda culpado